sie haben sein leben zerstört haben
ihnen seiner mutter weggenommen und ins
heim gesteckt die schweizer behörden mit
sechs jahren kam walter ms berger zu
pflegeeltern einem fahrers ehepaar das
in schwer misshandelte der hauptfehler
und den ohren gezogen und den augen und
geschlagen und den crash potter drin die
bms berger ist schwer traumatisiert kann
bis heute kaum eine kirche betreten
der hausmeister hat ein kleines museum
im keller des gemeindehauses seines
wohnortes fehraltorf eingerichtet hier
wird das leben spürbar sodass in der
schweizer staat verurteilt hatte
der 64 jährige und seine mutter gehörten
zu den rund 60.000 menschen die bis 1981
in der schweiz von den kantonsbehörden
administrativ versorgt wurden weil sie
nicht der norm entsprachen
sie wurden in gefängnisse wie dieses
gebracht hier wurde ms berger 1957
geboren
ich vermute dass meine mutter versorgt
wurde wollen sie ein uneheliches kind
erwartete das war damals hat man das so
genau dass man solche mitarbeit gesperrt
hat das passte nicht in die
gesellschaften von der schweiz damals
unter dem vorwand sie seien lieder nicht
trunk süchtig oder arbeitsscheu wurden
sie ins gefängnis in sogenannte
pflegefamilien oder in die psychiatrie
gebracht
dort sollten sie umerzogen werden mit
maßnahmen die ihre komplette entrechtung
und ausgrenzung zur folge hatten
historiker wos gehrmann bestätigen dass
es sich nicht um straftäter handelte er
hat im auftrag der schweizer regierung
für eine unabhängige
untersuchungskommission geforscht
bei den administrativ versorgten ging es
in der regel nicht um straftaten sondern
einfach nur um eine lebensweise die
nicht den gesellschaftlichen normen
entsprochen
schicksale wie das von walter m
essberger werfen einen schatten auf die
schweizer geschichte in rund 650
gefängnissen und anderen anstalten in
der schweiz wurden kinder und junge
erwachsene eingesperrt ausgebeutet und
vielfach schwer misshandelt auch ms
berger wurde hier im haus seiner
pflegeeltern stundenlang eingesperrt
er musste putzen im garten arbeiten und
auf dem feld er konnte uns nicht an den
tatort begleiten
ein versuch endete vor ein paar jahren
in einer panikattacke mit elf jahren
bringen in die paar leute in die
psychiatrische klinik münsterlingen
dort erreicht das martyrium des jungen
eine neue stufe am idyllischen bodensee
testet der klinikchef in den 60er 70er
jahren an ihm psychopharmaka
also was ich weiß ist einfach dass es
mir viel übel war schlecht also unsere
augen habe gehen dass ich auch platz
doch irgendwie dass ein wie ein anfall
bekam so dass two franiel scheint der
knabe nicht gut zu ertragen und wir
glauben dass die unangenehmen
erscheinungen die er zeigt
nebenwirkungen dieser medikation sind
dabei kam ich an schaute und wie sagt
man das genau stellung
die administrativ versorgten schweizer
hatten keine chance dem system zu
entkommen dass sie entrichtet hatte
deshalb kämpft walter ms berger nun
öffentlich um rehabilitation 25000
franken hat er aus einem
entschädigungsfonds der schweiz bekommen
der mitverantwortliche kanton thurgau
aber schreibt es seinen medikamenten
test durchgeführt worden
aber mangels weiterer studien lasse sich
das ausmaß noch nicht abschätzen
altersberger findet diese hinhaltetaktik
unerträglich zehntausende menschen seien
vom schweizer staat entrichtet worden
ihre qual dürfen nicht vergessen werden
kommt das ganze dunkle kapitel der
schweiz